naomi can you explain what a story goal
is
sure um the way i use it is really just
that it's that ultimate goal that your
sort of your whole story is structured
around so it's the thing that your
protagonist is trying to achieve in the
story um storyboard's just the easiest
way to describe it but it's that you
know it's in silence of the lambs it's
clear he's trying to catch the serial
killer buffalo bill her that's her story
goal right it's the um plot thing that
gives your entire story its structure
is the story goal also the story engine
uh well the character's pursuit of that
story goal i think is what creates the
engine and the story right so the
protagonist trying to achieve that thing
that's what drives the story forward
it's what moves the plot
so yeah i think the story goal is a
necessary part of that engine
can you give us examples of story goals
that work well so effective ones and
then ones that don't work well
sure um so effective story goals will
have some sort of external
component right so they can be
dramatized on screen in some way
ineffective story goals are are usually
very internal and things that we can't
see a character taking action toward we
can't see them pursuing you know if
you're writing a movie it's it's going
to be easier to to write it to structure
it if there's some sort of external
action or at least a way for
you to show us
what the character is doing and for us
to understand you know what they're
doing
um
let's see uh another thing that makes a
story goal effective is if it's
difficult enough to achieve that it will
take the whole movie to achieve right
you don't want something so easy
um or so
quick that it would be achieved in one
scene or a couple of scenes because you
need it to be difficult enough that your
character
can try to you know can attempt to
achieve it over 100 minutes or whatever
um and that difficulty can come from the
goal itself can be
difficult or it can also come from
there's just so much conflict in the way
right that your your character has a
hard time achieving it because there's
something or someone trying to stop them
if that does that make sense it does so
an internal goal
is hard because we unless it's a novel
we can't really tell what's going on
with the character
yeah and i think that yeah so in a
something that's very internal would be
hard for you to
would probably be difficult to show on
screen right unless you can find a way
to
dramatize it externally
um i think the movie short term 12 is a
good example of that
the
the story goal is
i think it's sort of twofold in that
movie but part of it is um
one of the things that the character is
going through is trying to open up right
um to be more
open emotionally which seems like it
would be hard to to show on screen right
like how do you show someone struggling
with that
um but i think they do a good job of of
really
clearly saying that it's it's if she can
talk about what happened to her in the
past i think that's how the story goes
if she can talk about what happened to
her
to her in the past to her fiance then
that's kind of the
you know the the milestone or the
benchmark that we're looking for to
indicate that she has achieved that goal
um so yeah if it's a very internal thing
if you can find a way to indicate that
that it's being pursued and that it's
been achieved then you can you know
that's dramatizing it you can make it
and something that you can shape your
movie around
and i think some actors are are really
fantastic at showing a very closed off
person i mean william hurt was always
great at playing somebody that you could
tell there was a lot going on inside but
he wasn't letting it out
probably would at some you know mid
point but
very contained and stifled and and so i
think there's certain certain actors
that really can play to that kind of
character yeah and i think even with
that though um
you know something like that something
like
you know if my goal is to learn how to
open up to other people
um
there are great actors who can play that
struggle of like i really want to open
up but i'm afraid to or i can't bring
myself to do it
even that can only sustain i think so
many scenes right and so it has to be
something that you can also
um
have other characters create conflict
with that with your protagonist you know
there has to be there have to be
obstacles in their way or opposing
forces that are making this difficult
for them as well if that if that makes
sense
why do you recommend the writer define
the goal and the method separately oh
well i think that that makes it easier
to wrap your head around your your own
story sometimes because the goal
the story goal that thing that the
protagonist is ultimately trying to
achieve it doesn't always imply
or indicate the kind of action that your
protagonist will be taking for most of
the movie right so i think um hell or
high water is a good example of this i
don't know if you've seen that movie
or we can talk about uh silence of the
lambs as well whatever one yeah yeah
that's okay the the goal um sometimes is
you know a very definite end point that
your character is working towards which
is great because that gives you the
framework for your story and again you
know it gives you that um the thing that
your audience is tracking so we know
where the character is headed and that
allows us to sort of understand are they
making progress are they having setbacks
but the method i think you know is is
sort of the missing piece sometimes if
you're trying to
you know break down your story and
figure out like what happens moment to
moment
because sometimes the the method is um
different or or
not implied by the story goal itself and
then a lot of times the method is
actually the entertaining thing about
the story it's like the thing that
people want to see in the movie so i
know these are examples that that are
foreign to you but um silence the lambs
like her goal is to catch the serial
killer right but the method she's using
is working with hannibal lecter which is
fascinating
that relationship is like part of the
you know the entertainment hook of the
of the movie so that's what we're
excited to watch it's also the chase and
trying to catch that serial killer but
the the really the scenes that everyone
remembers are the ones where she's
dealing with hannibal lecter and sort of
going toe-to-toe with him you know
mentally and matching wits with him
right and he's baiting her
and kind of showing that he's got the
upper hand right right and he's pushing
her in ways that other people don't push
her and sort of forcing her to you know
figure out that she's she can she can
handle it and she can do it and she can
you know catch the serial killer
it's a great relationship uh another
example of hell or high water just
really quickly since i brought it up um
his ultimate goal is to get the i think
it's 40 000
to the bank by
such whatever the deadline is right like
that's the ultimate goal that's what
he's working towards over the course of
the movie
but the method that he's using is he has
a plan to rob a series of small-town
texas banks right so that again that's
like where the entertainment value comes
from was we're watching him pull off
this carefully
you know planned series of bank heists
in small texas towns
um
that's entertaining and that if you were
writing that movie and you just knew
okay this guy needs to get this money to
the bank on time
that gives you the sort of big picture
framework but it's helpful for you the
writer to figure out like okay but
what's the what's the method what's the
more specific method that he's using to
do that because then that gives you that
act two
action right that you can go okay so
he's gonna do it by coming up with this
plan to rob all these banks in quick
succession okay how's he gonna do that
how many would you have to do in a day
and it it gives you more to work with
when you're coming up with the sort of
like scene by scene plotting of your
story you know why don't we ever hear
about writing a story and coming up with
a goal first
like
it seems like all we do is just want to
come up with this character and we're
kind of as you say we're really in love
with like the first act but the actual
story goal it seems like falls short for
many new writers do you think so um i'm
not sure i i feel like you know
you can sort of come at a story from a
lot of different ways
and
no matter which angle you you come to
that idea from no matter which kind of
aspect of it inspired you to want to
write it you still have to fill in all
of the other elements in order to kind
of like have a complete thing that can
work right
um i wonder if
i wonder if it feels that way because a
lot of times the story goal feels sort
of like
dry
plot very you know plot uh
specific and dry um and the interesting
part to a lot of writers is coming up
with the the character and the you know
the person that we're gonna go with on
this journey and coming up with those
like
traits that will be fun to write um and
this maybe the story goal just feels
like a
a thing that i have to figure out that i
you know don't really
i'm not inspired by i'm that could be it
well i know off camera you mentioned the
movie hustle the and we both saw it and
loved it is the story goal
the adam sandler goal or is the
basketball player's goal or are there
several story goals oh that's a good
question um so i when i talk about the
story goal i specifically mean the
protagonist story goal because that's
really what the
movie is structured around right like
that's the the character wanting that
thing is what gives you that spine of
the story um that sort of main through
line you might have heard it called um
so i would call the story goal in in
that movie adam sandler's goal which if
i were going to articulate it i'm not
sure i remember all the details of it
but it was like to
have
this basketball player be
picked up i'm not a sports person be
picked up by a team right
um did that does that sound right yeah i
think it was if i remember correctly was
he scouting out other players and
nothing was panning out either somebody
was too old or whatever and then he sees
this guy at like a street game if i
remember yeah and so it's kind of like
this unexpected he gets his wish
and now he's got to convince this guy to
come to the states yeah so so if we're
going to
kind of like you know look at that from
a 40 000 foot view of of the big picture
of the story like his story goal is the
thing he's trying to achieve by the end
of it
um and in that story i would say it's
it
that story goal is formed after he meets
that guy right so he
is sort of down on his luck he feels
like he's got one last chance to kind of
make his career happen we're talking
about the adam sandler character sure um
unexpectedly he sees this like you know
amazing miracle of a player and he's
like that's my chance if i can get that
guy a deal
and i think initially it's a deal with
the team that he works for and then they
kind of go out on their own or something
like that right but if i can get that
guy a deal then basically my career will
be saved so that becomes his and again i
wish i remembered all the details of
that story but i think that that's kind
of it that becomes his story goal then
that's the thing that he's working
towards for the rest of the movie so the
story goal isn't something that the
character starts the movie with it's
formed in act one so they you know start
the story sort of in their normal world
or their ordinary world or whatever um
and somewhere along the way in act one
they they form this story goal that is
the thing that drives the rest of the
movie so then pursuing that goal across
act two
and into act three and then resolving it
in act three that's you know that's the
rest of your movie
right and if i remember correctly i
think his back is against the wall
because
was the initial
coach or owner of the team like a mentor
and then
the dynamic changes and now there's a
new person at the helm
and
he's trying to and he's not really
fitting in well yeah so that's part of
the setup that that ben foster character
he becomes the team
owner i think or something like that
or whatever yeah yeah so he's kind of
like the bratty son yes exactly so the
the mentor character adam sandler's
mentor character was the owner he was
the older
the patriarch of that family he passes
away and then the son inherits it or
inherits that role anyway
um and he and adam sandler don't get
along so then that that like you said it
puts adam sandler's back up against the
wall and so then you know that's when
he's sort of in in a tough place where
he has okay i have one more chance i've
got one more chance to sort of save my
career otherwise i'm done
um because those circumstances have
changed and then that's when he sees the
basketball player and forms that story
goal